hey guys Peter Brown adjusted hey Walt
here from Val's event at CES where
they've just shown off 13 different
steam machines yeah talking with some of
the manufacturers are big they're small
some are expensive some are really
really expensive and some are pretty
cheap some a reasonably priced machines
is there any that really stood out to
you i'm holding the alienware one right
here very small compact form well you
know what they're going for with
something like this is something that
you can fit easily into into your home
entertainment system but didn't even
stand out to you pretty much everyone
stood out because they're all going for
different product categories at least to
me some are the same price as a new
console some are the same price has a
high end pc and then some are just so
small and we don't know the price of the
spec state that it's kind of a mystery
but anything that can be said is that
valve is really telling manufacturers to
go with what they want to build offer
the product that they're trying to sell
to customers there's no one steam
machine here everything is its own
little beast and valve is also you know
the one making the steam controller the
thing that we've been wanting to get our
hands on for so long but eventually
that's also something that they're going
to be handing over to other parties
valve does not want to be in the
hardware business they don't want to be
making these things but what did you
think of actually getting your hands on
that steam controller finally they might
not want to be in the hardware business
but they're off to a really good start
for something they don't care about um
the steam controller feels really good
it's got 17 discrete buttons I think
it's got the two track pads that have
like eight individual buttons on its own
face it's it's comfortable you can still
feel some of the haptics stuff needs to
be worked out things weren't calibrated
we played portal 2 they've also got
trying and they've got metro playing
here it's working it doesn't feel
perfect just yet but I think it's a
really good start and at least when
you're talking about ditching the
keyboard and the mouse for a controller
there yeah like I said they're off to a
pretty great start so far it takes a
little bit of getting used to but I felt
like once I once I got into the groove
and I figured out what all these
different buttons do there's some
buttons in surprising places I feel like
once I got used to that it it felt
really good funds in surprising places
there we go I think of anything right
now we can say that steam machines are
still young but they're growing at a
pretty rapid pace and it's just the
start of CES we're gonna have a lot more
to come stay tuned a gamespot follow us
on youtube on twitter on face
look I'm Peter Browns Justin hey Walt
thanks for watching